it's a bad sign that I've been doing
this for 20 seconds and I'm already had
a press I love the 80s I was a kid in
the 80s I don't care what decade we're
in I'm an out-of-shape piece of [ __ ] I'm
worried I won't be able to keep up
I might flash my nutsack at you Richard
Simmons is my boy we go way back all
right so we're going we're doing like a
thriller thing I love this this is just
like a music video Gyptian arms I never
hear that across fit is that racist
maybe what what am i doing I keep doing
the public I'm sorry but like who are
the people in this video and why are
they dressed for the office I kind of
like this though cause it's like not
exercise its just like bar Mitzvahed
dance moves if I could describe my
fitness it would be medium fit grandma
this woman's body is sick she's a thigh
gap but the ball between your legs oh
all these other grannies are coming this
is kinky [ __ ] if I can look like these
grannies by doing this I'm all for it my
ball is dropping
sure do you feel emasculated man this is
working my legs in a weird way I feel
like she's judging me if you're a
grandma that can hold a ball between
your legs you're probably already in
good shape for a grandma I hate this I
hate this what is this an exercise for
oh she's singing along swimming is
multi-talented it's kind of fun
Oh what this is crazy I got it they're
doing bad Bluff fur ball oh that granny
sub alright they are a little more
nimble than you give them credit for
this is the one that might kill me I got
the hang of this I was born in the 80s
damn it
okay wait all right start it over anyone
that can rock that leotard hot damn
what oh this is our exercise this is not
that different from what I do now
getting my pelvis ready for childbirth
yes yes yes estrogen estrogen estrogen I
feel empowered why are we doing this I
feel this one it's really escalated 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 fun guys
reminds me of my dancing days I like
feeling the momentum Oh get this what
it's going too fast I don't know what
you're doing you explain the move to me
I'm not good at this I can't do anything
that involves two body parts at once the
last guy who just was like all right
he's got it that guy got that holy [ __ ]
that was lots of fun I really want this
tape I'm not kidding it's a lot sillier
than exercise today is a rather just run
I like the community aspect like it's
just people in a room
these women have presents I get to keep
this oh right I wish this was all you
needed to do to get a six-pack because
the world would be a better place I'd
love to make the switch from actual
weights and AB core exercises to just go
ahead Wow how bigger ladies